brauch ich hab meine frage ist ein
schwangerschaftstest bekommen warum
mache ich nicht einfach mal ein
schwangerschaftstest möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen
servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute liebe leute
begeben wir uns wieder in die gut merken
der welt wie gut merken der menschheit
und damit natürlich auch in die guten
ecken von youtube de hat mir wieder mal
ein bisschen was vorgeschlagen weil sie
mir mal anschauen soll und dabei heraus
gekommen ist ich mache einen
schwangerschaftstest babys beauty palace
okay da war doch mal was mit youtube l
ist wir erinnern uns vor circa einem
monat habe ich ein video gemacht und das
hat mittlerweile einfach 1,1 millionen
auf wo wir nicht sind seit diesem video
sind viele dinge passiert
viele gute viele schlechte aber
eigentlich wird mal wieder zeit ja man
kann doch nicht die ganze zeit nur auf
abruf rumhacken das gilt auch nicht
bevor es losgeht wir zehn mal kurz mit
wir haben 123456 mal werbung auf einem
zehn minuten video baby sehr gut die
sache ist diese werbeblöcke diese gelben
künftigen sind rudeltiere die fühlen
sich alleine nicht wohl
deswegen ist es vorbildlich von baby das
sie so viel reingepackt sowie
artgerechte haltung wenn wir jetzt mal
in die erste zeile der beschreibung
schauen sehen wir kostenlos runterladen
sternchen das heißt heute geht es wieder
rund bei babys produkt palace ja ich
würde seine spiele wieder das placement
spiel das heißt die passende alle auf
wer zuerst das placement spotted gewinnt
los geht's okay alles klar dass schon
das erste lied da lagen auf jeden fall
nicht falsch unterstützt durch
produktplatzierung was auch sonst
meine frage ist ob so eine dumme
angeboten eigentlich selbst total nervt
und wenn ja welche sechs werbeblöcke pro
video zuschalten 36 werbeblöcke pro
video zuschalten
ja okay das ist auch wirklich stimmt es
gibt ein paar ausdrücke die sind
wirklich einfach übelste vergewaltigung
der deutschen sprache nämlich
tatsächlich alles gut und das wort super
als ersatz für viel oder sehr also
supergut supergeil super toll es ist ein
absolutes unding tatsächlich dem moment
wenn du zu oft tatsächlich sagst mir
irgendwelche komischen angewohnheiten
auf die immer aufmerksam der frack alter
jürgen kosten und nutzen stimmen bei
diesem video auf jeden fall nicht
überein
wir haben gerade baby zugehört wie sie
einer minute dreißig über das wort
tatsächlich geräte hat und das kommt
schon der erste werbeblocker adblock
rein st
angewohnheiten auf die immer aufmerksam
gemacht hat oder die welt zu werfen
[Musik]
rott place wird sie stellt uns eine app
vorleute das letzte video was man vom
baby angeschaut haben hat ja da fünf
produktplatzierungen das ist auch für bb
ein sehr guter wert und ich bin wirklich
gespannt ob sie denn heute kranken kann
ok alles klar
es geht darum stecken zu besiegen es war
sehr schwer in diesem spiel auf level
101 zu kommen meinte wie wir wirklich
auf level 101 gespielt die altbekannte
minecraft erzählerin und gamer rennt
meinte die hat von level 0 auf 100 1 1
gespielt oder hat er eventuell einen
account gegeben der schon vielleicht auf
level 100 1 1 war oder auf level 99 war
und sie tut jetzt so als wird sie das
spiel tatsächlich spielen aaron omen
wenn ihr ein letzte glauben wollt macht
das auf jeden fall gerne ich glaube auch
an let's be
was ist mit dieser kamera alter merkte
dass diese kamera wird die ganze zeit
unscharfen wieder also vielleicht
rausgeschnitten aber diese kamera kann
einfach nicht die schärfe halten baby
baby wir wissen euch gehts ein
finanziell sehr gut tut uns als
zuschauer doch bitte den gefallen und
kauft euch vernünftige kameras die
kosten keine unsummen an geld die kosten
vielleicht 1000 euro ja das macht ihr
nachtstunden bitte doch besser nach
[Musik]
kuchen
okay okay das ist das ist wirklich
anderer werden da muss ich wirklich
sagen bei all der ironie all den
zionismus das ist cool
ja baby die ihre reichweite was
positives einsetzt und auch mit
tierschutzorganisation peta aufmerksam
macht das finde ich echt gut und nicht
schon wieder werbung
nein nein jetzt mache ich eine glocke
reihen
hallo ich gebe mir doch nicht sechsmal
werbung bei den babys beauty palace
video also bei aller liebe ich habe
jetzt zweimal werbung gesehen die wie
ich hätte mir mehr als zweimal es geht
wirklich nicht das ist meine
schmerzgrenze erreicht
wenn du von allen menschen auf der welt
die einen auf wie konntest du mit einer
bratwurst schmeckt wäre wäre es wäre
natürlich julian ich weiß ganz genau wie
soll ich sonst sagen meine mutter runde
denn wenn ich mal dieses video vor
einfach so ab wie fies channel
ich schlage meine mutter mit einer
bratwurst und dann noch so wie bei baby
halt immer so mega viele images auf den
sammler alter wie geil wäre das das wir
mal youtube hey hey 2017
moment mal verspeist der julian etwa
öfters genüsslich bratwürste oder was
ist jetzt ein schwangerschaftstest baby
ich habe mich auf das video geklickt
weil ich wissen will wann urlaub
gefahren bist
hey ich hab eine frage ist ein
schwangerschaftstest bekommen warum
mache ich nicht einfach mal ein
schwangerschaftstest möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen ist dann
schnell ein video aus
wenn ich ein bisschen endlich über
kündigungen jetzt so wie ich bin das ja
ab und fuhren so was man es ist ja
nichts schlimmes an
schwangerschaftstests aber warum macht
man einen schwangerschaftstest in dem
video
[Musik]
der junge ist richtig gestört ich mag
das was habe ich heute gesehen ich
klicke einfach auf den babys youtube das
video weil mir das vorgeschlagen hat und
ich denke wieder regiert wieder die
hölle ab und es ging auf die hölle ab
wir hatten natürlich ein placement wie
es prolactal ist hat wieder zugeschlagen
ich meine der titel heißt ich mache
einen schwangerschaftstest aber dass man
dann wirklich ein schwangerschaftstest
im video macht okay leute wenn ihr wollt
dass ich ein schwangerschaftstest mache
dann lassen fast einen kommentar ab bis
zum nächsten mal haut rein macht es gut
und ein verstörtes zeit what the [ __ ]
alter